[Music]
in one of our earlier videos on the 20
powers of godzilla we included the alpha
call that was seen
in the king of the monsters movie of
2019 and we will compare this to the
similar alpha command or call that the
dragons
had in the franchise of how to train
your dragon and we will see how
different they are
and also the similarities between them
but before you continue on with this
video do spare some time and check out
our mind qt springs tour as we have
quite a number of merch
that are up for grabs it would mean a
lot to us if you extend your support
and also for the ones subscribed to us
do click that notification bell for
regular updates
so here goes the video in how to train
your dragon the alpha has been seen
providing food projection and peace for
the other dragons
as well as commanding its subordinates
with a unique sound frequency
so the role of the alpha is worn by
combat it seems very likely that alphas
are almost always massive dragons
with toothless being an incredibly
unlikely case the bewildered bees has
been seen referring
to as an alpha species and this may be
because
of their size and the natural hypnotic
ability that lead them
often to rise to that rank an ability
also seen in the red death
as it can send out a command that can
hardly be ignored by other smaller
dragons
so alphas hold the ability to very
strongly manipulate the wills of other
dragons
and do their bidding by an alpha call in
the most verse however the titan who is
the strongest of the group is recognized
by the other
inferior titans as the alpha or the apex
predator
in godzilla king of the monsters this
title comes along with a sound frequency
that when used
other titans are forced to obey so
godzilla initially holds this alpha core
but later in the movie
monster zero temporarily took this role
of being the alpha after managing
to defeat rodan in battle and surviving
the oxygen destroyer weapon that
almost left godzilla dead at the bottom
of the ocean
and as such the alpha call that he made
on top of the mountain
over isla de mara sounded all over the
world and the titans rose up from their
slumber to do his bidding and destroy
humanity
so how do these two alpha calls compare
against each other
well let's start with the dragons as
they came up with this idea first
in the first movie we see the red death
and its ability to force other dragons
to its will
seen when it used to force dragons to
bring it
a constant supply of food it laid there
in its lair
waiting for the other dragons the
smaller dragons to bring it food
or if they fail she would just come up
and eat the smaller ones or the slower
ones
so her hypnotic alpha call can be used
to force dragons even far away like
hundreds of miles away
to do her bidding as seen when these
dragons rate birth for food even though
the island is situated beyond the
horizon
the one used by the bewilder beast seems
to be only effective at close range but
very highly effective at that
and in the monster verse as said earlier
when monster zero or ghidorah sounded
his alpha call
it could be heard all around the world
and titus that were hibernating
all the way in africa or australia were
goals to wake up and start hunting
destroying human cities like a
synchronized team we find out that
these types of calls were a result of
the titan's bioacoustics and that these
were
in the ultrasonic wavelength or range
that
cannot be heard by us humans and can
travel thousands of miles in any
direction
given that the source was intense enough
in fact the 2014 godzilla movie hinted
at such abilities when the male muto and
the female muter were communicating with
each other
over the length of the pacific ocean so
the similarities between these two alpha
calls that both can be used to dominate
the other subordinate species of their
kind
or titan kind as in the monster verse
and as seen when the bewildered beasts
commanded toothless to kill hiccup
the saudi maid was not understood or
heard by the humans
and only by dragons so we could say that
the alpha call
or sound was also ultrasonic in its
frequency
the same as the titans called when the
mutos or godzilla or ghidorah sounded
their calls
and they were barely heard by any human
except for the ones in the vicinity of
the area
but the other titans that can understand
the command or their call from thousands
of miles away
similarly the alpha call depends on the
type of alpha in both franchises
in dragons the alpha holds the ability
to very strongly manipulate the wills of
other dragons
vulcans bewildered bees use this ability
sparingly
while drago's bewildered beast abused it
to the extreme drago goes so far as to
say that no dragons can resist an
alpha's command
similarly in the monster verse one can
hardly hear or see godzilla using the
call
to manipulate or command other titans
but ghidorah abused it and set
them in a rampage one can also see in
both cases that only the ones
willing to challenge the alpha status of
being themselves alpha species can
resist
and even sound their own one big
difference
between these two types of calls is the
human factor in the monster verse
human sounds or bio-acoustics can be
used alongside other titans
by acoustics with the help of a device
called the orca to generate an alpha
frequency that is unique
and could stop the titans from
destroying the world there is no such
thing seen in dragons only that
drago's bewildered bees obeys his master
out of being trained to do so
and not due to drago's voice and at the
same time other dragons hardly pay heed
to drago
although it may be a factor of
technology as vikings wouldn't have even
known about
what electricity was back in those days
so dragons came from hundreds of miles
away in every direction to burke
to pay heed to the new alpha and when
toothless leaves for the hidden world
at the end of the third movie it also
shows that even though he can't control
minds like a bewilderbies
he can force dragons to obey him without
needing to be in an alpha mode
he is accepted as the one and the only
king to which all dragons bow to in the
hidden world
even without an alpha frequency as
generated by the willoughbys
godzilla 2 didn't have to use it often
but he did have his own alpha call
and so did the others and maybe kong
does too who knows
so that's another big difference the
alpha status in dragons could be more
than just
sound it does have some element of magic
as do all dragons do
so would these calls work on either
universes i don't know
if a dragon like the b willow beast
sends its hypnotic call with the titans
of the most of us bay heat
or would they treat it like a mosquito
sun and similarly
if ghidorah who is also a dragon himself
sounds to his dreaded alpha call
with the dragons be compelled to obey it
like they did to the red death
and drago's bewildered beasts we will
leave this to your imagination and to
your comments down below
so we have now come to the end of this
video it was short but do like share and
subscribe
and tell us what we might have missed
out with this theory
till next time take care